a lot of music doesn't get put out
a vast majority of Music doesn't get bit
out are there some amazing songs out
there that you think have been made that
or have we're not have not been put out
there's a lot of a lot of songs out
there that I shouldn't think shouldn't
have been put out
um
there's a lot of amazing songs I've
heard in studios that never came out for
sure yet like
hundreds hundreds and they're honestly
feels like a crime honestly it feels
like a crime it's it's terrible
when you hear them and you're like oh I
can't wait
I can't wait for that to come out on
people to hear it and
yeah because if something happens like
promo doesn't work out like someone
somebody like an anr says I'm not really
sure about that one or someone says to
the artist like what a friend of theirs
says oh I don't like that one and it
just turns them off it
or they develop negative association
with that song it's happened with me
plenty of times I mean I've got songs
and
my hard drive is Thousands thousands of
songs that haven't made the cut or
they missed their moment
you know some songs just feel like a
moment and it's like if you don't put
them out soon oh yeah you're not you
just you're not gonna uh you're never
gonna feel like that again
or maybe sometimes like I didn't nail
the vocal take I didn't fully um so I
don't like the way I'm singing so and I
can't be bothered going back and singing
it again so there's all these songs that
the actual DNA of the song is good
but
you can't be bothered doing it again
going back into that place
yeah and you can't get back there it's
kind of the value of a moment it's like
sometimes you know it's like man we were
so close right there for that moment
yeah and it's like sometimes those
things are batches of songs so like
there'll be a batch of songs that
sounded like
retrograde or there'll be a batch of
songs that sounded like say what you
will but say what you will was the best
of that batch and retrograde was the
best of that batch so I put that out
instead of lots of kind of cop kind of
similar tone songs in a similar tone
that like one is good
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one